Kelly Lefler the Republican senator who
lost to Rafael Warnock in Georgia in
2021 says her organization is going to
be helping out Herschel Walker I don't
know if that's a promise or a threat
from Kelly Leffler based on how things
went she appeared on Fox Business and
she said we're going to help Herschel
we're going to help Herschel check this
out throw Governor Kemp has thrown
throwing his ground game behind it as
are we and the key here is that we want
everyone to come in and support this
effort but this effort is about
Georgians and I'm calling on Georgians
to get involved to support Herschel yeah
so Kelly Lefler she's got a lot of money
Kelly Lefler and her husband reportedly
are worth about 800 million dollars
there's no doubt she has money to
contribute to this effort we have to
hope that it's yet another failure and
that the outcome is exactly the same as
the outcome from 2021 remember in 2021
this was because of the 50 rule in
Georgia both Georgia Senate seats in
2021 in 2020 rather went to special
elections which took place on January
5th 2021 we covered them you may
remember John ossoff Won and Raphael
Warnock won Warnock is the one who faced
off against Kelly Lefler Warnock won by
two percent of the vote
um it was just under a 100 000 vote
margin so the hope is the Hope is that
again some Republicans won't vote
because they feel it's rigged listen I'm
not going to go out there and try to
suppress the vote it's not my move but
if they want to tell themselves on each
other don't bother voting because it's
rigged and your vote won't vote won't
matter by all means tell each other that
that's absolutely fine and if indeed the
same failed ground game that lost Kelly
lefler's election in 2020 2021 is going
to be in play here I say absolutely
fantastic thing let's let them do it now
that being said
you know no matter what position I take
a portion of the audience is mad and
this is this happens with just about
every election what's my real feeling
about this Georgia runoff
my real feeling is it's probably like
a 55 ish percent chance Warnock wins 55
maybe 60 chance based on the totality of
everything that's going on and how
previous special elections have gone
just all these different things
no matter what numbers I assess or no
matter what polling I look at it's
always the same thing with the audience
and I think we could much more
productively deal with this I'm not a
news show I'm a commentary show so when
you take a race like this if I say to
you listen
um the polls are basically split 50 50
but based on you know everything from
more Republicans died of covid than
Democrats so it killed more Republican
voters to special elections in Georgia
recently have been good for the
Democratic candidate combined with
there's maybe some right wing polls that
are averaged in that are not too trust
okay some people will write to me and
say David
you are dissuading democratic voters
from voting were you when you say I
think it's probably a 55 or 60 chance
that Warnock wins voters in Georgia will
hear that Democratic voters and they're
going to stay home it's very dangerous
what you're doing okay
if I understate the degree of support I
get emails from people who say David and
I got these when I was just looking at
polling with caveats leading up to last
week's midterm people would email me and
say David
why are you buying into this right-wing
narrative that Republicans are going to
do well it's all push-poling in Georgia
these are trash right-wing polls and if
voters Democratic voters hear you say
Walkers leading they're going to stay
home
first of all it's a sort of you're
damned if you do damned if you don't
situation I'm not creating the polls and
I'm not doing news reporting I'm
synthesizing what's out there and giving
you my opinion which is I think the
circumstances slightly favor Warnock I
don't know whether the polling we have
between now and December 6 which is so
soon will really be trustworthy it could
go either way everyone should vote
that's that's the reality
any position
can be used to claim that I'm doing the
wrong thing and by the way
any position could also be used to say
well that means we really should vote
right if the truth is oh this is 50 50
and it's leaning red that's not a reason
for Democrats to stay home that's a
reason for Democrats to get out to vote
so let's allow ourselves to recognize
simultaneously
we only have certain numbers of things
we can look at to figure out what is
going on and it's okay to look at those
things and also at the end of the day
cheering and booing doesn't count for
who wins and polling doesn't count for
who wins voting counts for who wins
let's allow ourselves to understand
those things all right make sure you're
following us on Instagram at
davidpackman show what's Happening by
the way with the big announcement
tonight we'll talk about that next